so getting into the age of ultron
prelude comic that is to say this tie in
the first thing we need to establish
here is that for those of you guys who
are unaware ever since Marvel first
introduced the Marvel Cinematic Universe
since it was launched with Iron Man 1
Marvel's been systematically really I
guess releasing various comic book
tie-ins for a lot of these films we of
course saw a prelude for Thor the dark
world we know that there's a couple pre
alludes coming up for ant-man and these
are designed to kind of fill in the
blanks but not really give us the whole
story age of Ultron is a perfect example
with the age of Ultron tie and what we
find I guess over the course of this
story is that this comic seems to take
place over the course of maybe the very
beginnings of Captain America the Winter
Soldier throughout the movie and then at
the end but I would say if it really
does encompass this window it's a very
small compass that is to say that it
takes place immediately before during
and immediately after but what we know
is that of course over the course of the
events of a Captain America the Winter
Soldier that Hydra was basically in
control of shield they've been slowly
infiltrating shield for years and this
was finally the time under Alexander
piers for them to make their move and so
as a result what we find is that after
the events of Avengers that shield was
in possession of Loki's staff but one of
the shield agents who was monitoring the
staff had gone rogue and as a result it
was revealed that he was part of Hydra
had handed the staff over to Baron von
Strucker now if you recall the end of
Captain America the Winter Soldier we
have seen that Baron von Strucker was
basically talking about how this was the
age of miracles which again is really
Marvel's way of basically saying mutants
are being introduced to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they simply just
can't call them mutants and so as a
result we had I guess it had been
revealed to us that Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch were part of the process
and so what this comic does is more or
less tell us how it was it became part
of the fold what we find is that
apparently Hydra under Baron von
Strucker is operating out of some kind
of war-torn country to country called
sokovia
now my geography is not the best in the
world and so I'm not really sure if
sokovia is actually a country or not but
I would go as far as I say that is
probably a fictional location but what
we know is that because this country is
war-torn of course there are various
people who are protesting and so on and
the Scarlet Witch were revealed to be a
couple of them now what Baron von
Strucker tells us here is that his goal
I guess is immediate goal seemed to be
to develop some kind of weapon systems
based on the staff
of Loki that is to say some kind of guns
that can be used by the staff being
powered or perhaps in some way tied to
the tesseract but what we also see is
that Baron von strucker's a bigger goal
here is to perhaps create some measure
of super soldiers who have abilities
based on the power of the staff and so
when the questions asked of him how is
it he's going to go about being able to
around people a lot to move into human
testing what he says is they're
surrounded by people in this war-torn
country who want to take their country
back now we don't know if the country is
I guess being occupied or if those who
are oppressing these people are Hydra
themselves or if Hydra simply just
operating out of this country and
they're bribing the government to allow
that to keep happening or if in fact the
control the government these are things
that really aren't given to us but what
Baron von Strucker says is that they
should go out and basically start
rounding these people up and that's what
happens what they do is entice them by
simply saying that if they want to take
the country back that Hydra has the
means for them to do it and so among the
people who were brought into this
program are Pietro and Wanda Maximoff
now with a Scarlet Witch her powers are
a little more complicated here of course
citing her role in the comics we know
that as time progressed leading up to
Avengers disassembled she had basically
been altering reality we're not really
told if that's the case here what we're
told is that her power composure I guess
consists of two components the first one
is neuroelectric sensitivity and the
second is micro cellular manipulation
now we don't know if by virtue of her
micro cellular manipulation is she's
able to control the human body that is
to say the biology and the cells that
compose bodies or if she can control
batteries and the reason why I say that
is because when it comes to the concept
of micro cellular it's split into those
two categories micro cellular can very
well be the things that make up
batteries it's what makes up a I guess
battery based components and allows
batteries to function so she could
simply be able to manipulate the life of
batteries which would be a pretty
lackluster ability and truth but I would
go as far as to say that her ability
with with regards to micro cellular
manipulation is they be able to the
ability to control micro cells or I
guess a very basic cell cells a contain
a nucleus and proteins just enough to
basically keep it alive now the other
half of this is of course again her
neuro electric sensitivity now this I
think really points to the trailer that
we had seen where the Incredible Hulk
was going on a rampage fighting against
Tony Stark with red rays around his eyes
I would go as far as to say that under
neuroelectric sensitivity she's able to
basically control them
of others and the reason I say that is
because neuro immediately tells me that
it has to do with the mind and electric
means it probably has to do with the
electrical impulses that are sent from
the brain to the rest of the body in
order for the body to do it needs to do
and so she can probably control the mind
and by extension control the actions of
other people but again this is all just
a lot of speculation here are really not
sure about a lot of these different
things the whole purpose of this tie and
it's to basically get us prepared for
what's going to be coming in the movie
to sort of set this very basic landscape
and the events as far as they lead up to
the Avengers 2 age of Ultron with that
being said I'm going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly